Zombieland I really liked you in in
Zombieland I thought there was a great
part
yeah they cash saved that film has cast
a bunch of nobodies
are we gonna sell this thing get
Middleditch in there quick Jesse who
yeah Jesse Eisenberg yeah exactly huh
yeah woody huh
Jesse I know it's very clever to cast
you as sort of the alter-ego to Jesse
Eisenberg like kind of almost like an
alternate version of him alternate yeah
I remember years ago this was before
kind of anything I think before even I
had done a film I I remember auditioning
for Zombieland out for his part Oh for
his boy yeah I mean so in a way in a way
I finally got to do it but in a
completely different sense but it's kind
of neat that's a gun that's a fun but
now Hollywood story I envisioned for it
did was it not a sequel was it awkward
then to meet him did he know that you
had tried to get his part and that he
had been the victor you had in fact lost
I mean he was pretty nice face to face
it was only when I went back to my
trailer and found it burned to the
ground did I realize that he still held
on to something even though he won yeah
yeah yeah if it was more like a victory
burning yeah I track oh he had to show
you you know who was the Alpha yeah